[MUSIC]
An excellent organization is one where
people do the right thing even when
nobody's watching them
over their shoulder.
Because that's what
makes you best in class,
that's actually what makes you innovative.
That's actually what's the foundation for
being a place that employees love to work.
So that's the hardest thing, how do
you build an organization where people
do the right thing even when
nobody is watching all over them?
[MUSIC]
Accountability to me is not a list of
metrics, accountability is what you feel,
so felt accountability
is the important thing.
And from my point of view,
there are two foundations,
one is a feeling of
psychological ownership,
the other is a sense of obligation,
and each one balances the other.
If it's 100% psychological ownership,
0% obligation,
it becomes a gateway to being egocentric.
On the other hand if
it's 100% obligation and
no sense of psychological ownership,
that becomes burdensome and
therefore unsustainable, so
you need a blend of both things.
[MUSIC]
The problem I have with most executives
is all that they think about is geez,
we've got to crank the incentive lever.
In short, we gotta pay people more,
the more we pay people,
apparently the more accountable they feel,
I'm not so sure.
Instead, you can actually
do more lightweight things,
as a matter of fact,
with my colleague Lindy Greer and
a wonderful graduate
student Jennifer Daniels,
the three of us did an interesting
experiment with ATT new venture teams.
What did we do?
We randomly put these
teams into two conditions,
the control condition which
I won't bother you about.
And then a treatment condition, these
teams were teams of four to five people.
And all that we asked team members
in the treatment condition was,
choose a job title that
showcases your unique strength.
And people came up with titles like
guru of software or the queen bee of
customer service, or the defender of
the code or whatever, it was amazing.
The teams where people chose their
own job titles what did it do?
It actually made them feel
less anonymous obviously,
it improved their sense of self-esteem.
But much more importantly, it also solved
the problem of who knows what in the team.
They were able to build
prototypes that were quicker and
better than others in
the control condition.
My question to you is,
does it cost you anything to ask people
to come up with their own title?
[MUSIC]
In most organizations when I look
at high performers, on average,
high performers can be
categorized into two buckets.
One bucket is high performers
who are high maintenance,
they need to be stroked,
they need to be paid,
they need to be recognized, and
they're extremely self-centered.
On the other hand,
there are other high performers who have
been referred to as extra milers,
and what do they do?
They perform well, but
they're also the most helpful people.
They're the go-to people when you run into
a problem, hey how do I deal with this
customer problem,
how do I deal with the technology problem?
It's these extra milers that do the most,
it turns out most executives
they overload the extra-milers.
You're never going to go
to your high maintenance,
high performance, high performer and
say can you please do that.
They'll just immediately want
a lot of things from you,
you instead go to your extra-milers.
They're very good at what they do,
what's their principle weakness?
They don't know how to say no to you,
or for that matter anybody.
So ironically the more you overload them,
the more overwhelmed they get.
And some studies have actually shown
that if you overload them with too many
requests, they actually begin to develop
intentions of leaving the company.
Is that what we want to do?
I think not.
[MUSIC]